>>> ASK WEST ANY QUESTION ABOUT
VIRTUALLY ANYTHING AND THE
CONVERSATION MOVES BACK TO HIS
FAITH IN GOD WHICH IS CLEARLY
FOUNDATIONAL AND IS DRIVING HIS
CONFIRMATION FROM A POP STAR TO
WHAT HE HOPES TO BECOME IS A
SPIRITUAL LEADER.
HE EXPLAINED IT IN THIS CLIP.
>> WHAT IS YOUR PRAYER LIFE
LIKE?
DO YOU PRAY A LOT?
>> THIS IS A PRAYER.
WE ARE IN CONSTANT PRAYER.
I THOUGHT HAIL MARY CAME TO ME
NOT IN A CATHOLIC WAY BUT MORE
IN NOTE TO PLAXICO HER WEIGH.
LIKE COME WITH ME, HAIL MARY.
WHAT DO WE HAVE HERE NOW.
DO YOU WANT TO RIDE OR DIE.
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD THAT?
IT'S LIKE A NEGRO SPIRITUAL.
IT'S A CHANT.
IT PUT YOU IN THAT MODE.
I'VE GOT A SONG THAT I MADE IT
WAS LIKE A HYBRID OF THAT AND
LED ZEPPELIN.
IT'S LIKE MY BEST SONG.
WAIT TILL I GET MY MONEY RIGHT.
LAW, LAW.
THEN YOU CAN'T TELL ME NOTHING
RIGHT.
I CAN OPEN UP THIS STUFF.
I CAN OPEN UP TOURS WITH THIS
SONG.
I WANTED TO POINT OUT THIS
HYBRID.
IF YOU SEE ZOMBIE LAND ONE AND
ZOMBIE LAND TWO OR TERMINATOR,
THEY ALWAYS MAKE THE CHARACTERS
A LITTLE BIT BETTER IN THE NEXT
GENERATION.
KIM IS LIKE A HYBRID.
SHE IS NOT JUST MARILYN MONROE.
SHE'S ALSO A FASHION PERSON.
SHE'S ALSO A MOM.
SHE'S ALSO AN ACTIVISTS.
SHE'S A LAWYER.
SHE'S A MULTIBILLIONAIRE.
SHE IS HOT.
SHE'S ONE OF THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
PEOPLE OF ALL TIME.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT LEVEL OF
VIDEOGAME CHARACTERS.
WHEN YOU SEE A HEADLINE THAT
SAYS, KIM SAYS, I WILL STAY
SINGLE FOREVER, THAT'S THE
INDOCTRINATION.
BECAUSE THEY WANT THIS PERSON TO
TELL ALL THE LITTLE GIRLS OUT
THERE THAT THEY NEED TO BE
SINGLE FOREVER.
I KNOW THERE IS DEFINITELY
PEOPLE WATCHING.
>> YOU DON'T THINK THAT'S AN
ORGANIC, NATURAL THING.
THAT'S A MESSAGING BEING USED TO
SEND?
TO MAKE ABSOLUTELY.
THINK ABOUT THE SONG DON'T TALK
ABOUT BRUNO.
IT'S ALREADY WEIRD.
IT'S LIKE TALKING ABOUT AN UNCLE
THAT DID SOMETHING WRONG.
DON'T TALK ABOUT BRUNO.
LISTEN TO THE LYRICS.
IT SAYS THE MAN OF MY DREAMS
WILL BE SLIGHTLY OUT OF MY
REACH.
I SEE MY KIDS RUNNING AROUND AND
I SEE THESE THINGS.
FOR THE EXECUTIVES AT DISNEY
THAT ARE STUDYING EVERYTHING I
AM DOING OR SAYING AND TRYING TO
CONNECT WITH 15 -YEAR-OLDS.
THAT'S WHY INSTEAD OF PUTTING A
TRUE SKATER DESIGNER THEY PUT A
BLM MANAGER AS THE HEAD OF
SUPREME BECAUSE SUPREME HAS AN
IMPACT WITH THE 15 -YEAR-OLDS.
FOR THE DISNEY GUYS, YOU MIGHT
NOT BELIEVE IN GOD, BUT GOD
BELIEVES IN YOU.
IT'S NOT A BATTLE YOU CAN WIN.
DON'T JUMP ANAKIN, I HAVE THE
HIGHER GROUND TYPE OF SITUATION.
YOU CAN PUT OUT ALL THE
INDOCTRINATION AND MOVES AND
HAVE THE BIGGEST MEDIA COMPANY,
BUT WHY AM I ALIVE?
WHY AM I PROTECTED?
WHY DID I BECOME THE RICHEST
BLACK MAN OF ALL TIME?
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
THE MORE AND MORE I LEAN INTO
GOD AND WORK FOR GOD, THE MORE
WINS GOD IS GOING TO BESTOW ON
OUR TEAM, ON JESUS TEAM.
FOR ME TO GO OUT AND STATE AN
OBVIOUS AND EMPATHETIC STATEMENT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE MOST
LIBERAL CENTRAL.
THAT WAS LIKE TIANANMEN SQUARE.
WITH CANDACE OWENS.
WE BOTH WORE THE SHIRT AT THE
SAME TIME.
WE'VE GOT SOME JESUS SOLDIERS
OUT HERE.
PEOPLE SAY THEY ARE WILLING TO
DIE FOR IT, BUT WE LIVE FOR IT.
WE ARE LIVING FOR THE BATTLE.
WHAT IS THE BATTLE FOR?
LIFE ITSELF.
OUR CHILDREN.
THEY ARE KILLING US THROUGH THE
FOOD.
CONTENT.
THEY ARE KILLING US THROUGH THE
PROGRAMMING.
BUT GOD IS ALIVE AND HE IS ALIVE
IN ALL OF US.
WE WILL OVERCOME.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU ARE
HOPEFUL FOR THE FUTURE OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> ABSOLUTELY, BECAUSE I HAVE
THE VISION FOR IT.
I UNDERSTAND THE ECOSYSTEM.
I UNDERSTAND HOW TO EVEN
LIBERATE BIG PHARMA.
I HAVE SOLUTIONS FOR THE FUTURE.
I DON'T HAVE THE ENTIRE VISION.
CERTAIN THINGS ARE JUST IN FRONT
OF ME AND THEY HAPPENED WHEN
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN.
THERE ARE SO MANY OPEN DOORS.
WE HAVE THIS CONCEPT.
THIS WAS PUT ON MY HEART.
THE IDEA OF A MONASTERY.
IT TAKES THE DIFFERENT
DISCIPLINES AND BLENDS THEM
TOGETHER.
THE DUNDAS THEORY WE HAVE PROPER
BABY HEALTHCARE.
I AM SURE WHEN I MET WITH GABY
SHE HAD A REALLY GOOD TERM FOR
THIS.
SO MANY PEOPLE BRING BABIES TO
THE HOSPITAL.
THE DOCTOR IS MESSED UP.
THERE HAS BEEN COMPLICATIONS.
TO HAVE INCREDIBLE NURSES.
I WAS VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT SAYING
NURSES INSTEAD OF SAYING DOCKERS
TOO.
I DON'T BELIEVE YOU NEED A
DOCTOR.
I AM NOT A DOCTOR, BUT A NURSE.
IT'S POSSIBLE TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL CHILDBIRTH.
THAT'S THE FIRST THING WE
PROVIDE, SHELTER.
WE WILL NOT TURN ANYONE AWAY.
FOOD, CLOTHING, HIGH-END
CURRICULUM AND VOCATIONAL
CURRICULUM.
FARMING, CARPENTRY, AUTOMOTIVE,
COMPUTER SOFTWARE AND HARDWARE.
IT BECOMES A NEW PLACE WHERE
SOMEONE CAN LAY THE BABY ON
THEIR STEPS AND SAY THE
SITUATION I AM IN, I DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY FOR ANOTHER KID.
I DON'T HAVE THE TIME.
I DON'T HAVE THE ROOM AND MY
HOUSE.
I JUST DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES.
EVERY DAY FOR THE PAST TWO
MONTHS I HAVE BEEN WALKING BY
THIS PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND
THINKING ABOUT STOPPING IN.
I JUST CAN'T HAVE THIS BABY.
WHAT I AM DOING IS SAYING LET'S
PUT A PLACE ACROSS THE STREET
FROM THE PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND
SAY THIS IS A PLACE THAT WHEN
YOU DECIDE TO HAVE YOUR CHILD,
THIS CHILD CAN HAVE THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY AT LIFE.
>> DO YOU THINK SOCIETY
DISCOURAGES PARENTAL
INVOLVEMENT, PARENTAL INFLUENCE
OVER THE CHILDREN?
>> I MEAN, SOCIETY IS A BIG
TERM.
>> IT IS.
YOU SAID YOUR FATHER WAS
DISCOURAGED FROM BEING IN YOUR
HOUSEHOLD AND YOU HAVE BEEN
CHILDREN'S LIVES.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A THING
THAT HAPPENS TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN AMERICA, TO A LOT OF MEN?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND A LOT OF MEN DEAL WITH A
MOTHER, THE BABY MAMA, AND THE
MOTHER-IN-LAW GANGING UP TO TAKE
THE CHILD AWAY.
AND NOT WANTING TO GIVE THE DAD
HIS SAY-SO.
THERE WAS EVEN A MOMENT WHERE WE
WERE ARGUING ABOUT NORTH'S
BASKETBALL COACH.
I HAD TO SAY I WENT FROM NOT
MAKING A BASKETBALL TEAM IN
EIGHTH GRADE TO WINNING
CHAMPIONSHIPS IN NINTH GRADE BY
PRACTICING EVERY DAY.
NORTH LIKES BASKETBALL.
I'M GOING TO COME AND PRACTICE
WITH HER EVERY DAY.
I WILL ALSO PICK THE OTHER
COACHES THAT.
WITH HER.
NOW THAT SHE IS BACK PLAYING
BASKETBALL, THIS IS THE MOST
CONFIDENT PERSON IN THE LEAGUE.
SHE'S LIKE DENNIS RODMAN.
WHEN NORTH SNATCHES THE BALL OUT
OF A GIRL TWICE HER SIZE AND SHE
COMES OVER TO THE SIDE, I TELL
HER, DON'T LET ANYONE TAKE
ANYTHING FROM YOU EVER.
DON'T LET ANYONE TAK